[Music]  in this class i want to share with you  my writing process and what comprises a  song  [Music]  when i start a song most of my songs  start with a mumble track and what i'm  doing the only thing i'm worried about  is the melody and the structure of the  song  the bridge  is like  more rapid fire lyrics building tension  and then landing again  at our chorus  i just wrote a brand new song called  free i start with a melody  let it wash through the valley saw to  the mountains  fall in the deepest blue sea what unique  thing do you want to put out into the  world  whether you want to make a moment or  start a movement this songwriting class  is for you we'll see  rain down free to rain down till we're  [Music]  go down to every land  [Music]